digamos que tenemos una reacción del
segundo orden en a entonces se convierte
en nuestros productos y por aquí tenemos
el tiempo cero la concentración inicial
de a y después de un tiempo t tenemos la
concentración de a al tiempo t ahora si
queremos expresar la velocidad de esta
reacción podemos por ejemplo tomar la
velocidad promedio que es igual como
estamos tomando el reactivo tenemos que
poner un signo menos por aquí y en el
numerador ponemos el cambio en la
concentración de a y en el denominador
ponemos el cambio en el tiempo ya hemos
hecho esto en unos vídeos anteriores
ahora esta no es la única forma que
tenemos de expresar la velocidad de esta
reacción también podemos escribir la
velocidad instantánea utilizando la ley
de velocidad de esta reacción que la
velocidad instantánea de la reacción es
igual a la constante de velocidad de
esta reacción
por la concentración de nuestro reactivo
y como dijimos que es una reacción de
segundo orden en a entonces tenemos que
elevar la concentración de a al cuadrado
ok y aquí lo que nos gustaría hacer es
igualar estas dos expresiones pero aquí
hay un pequeño problema porque esta es
la velocidad promedio a lo largo de todo
este intervalo sin embargo aquí podemos
utilizar cálculo que bueno si estás
viendo este vídeo espero que se pasó un
poco de cálculo pero bueno si tomáramos
intervalos en el tiempo cada vez más
pequeños esto de aquí es igual a menos
la derivada de la concentración de a con
respecto al tiempo
y ahora sí ya es la velocidad
instantánea de la reacción en un tiempo
dado y entonces lo podemos igualar a
esta parte de aquí aquí o sea es igual a
por la concentración de a al cuadrado y
listo aunque ya tenemos nuestra ecuación
diferencial y nada más la vamos a
modificar un poco para poder encontrar
una ecuación que describa cómo se
modifica la concentración de a a lo
largo del tiempo con ok vamos a resolver
esta ecuación diferencial y como
resultado vamos a obtener una función
que describe la concentración de a a lo
largo del tiempo y bueno cuando queremos
resolver ecuaciones diferenciales
generalmente queremos todas las
expresiones de un tipo de un lado del
igual y las otras del otro vamos a
necesitar más espacio
pasamos la concentración de al cuadrado
dividiendo de este lado y la verdad es
que queremos poner el diferencial de t
del lado derecho no podemos decir que
multiplicamos por el diferencial de t
pero pues esta ecuación si es
equivalente a la que voy a poner a
continuación menos
de la concentración de a entre la
concentración de a al cuadrado es igual
acá de t y ahora sí ya estamos listos
para integrar pero para que sea más
fácil vamos a volver a escribir esta
parte como estamos dividiendo entre la
concentración de a al cuadrado esto es
igual a tomar la concentración de a y
elevarla a la menos 2 y luego tenemos t
igual acá dt entonces pues vamos a
integrar como que a es una constante
sale de la integral y vamos a regresar
arriba para ver cuáles son nuestros
límites de integración aunque supongo
que yo te los imaginas ahora aquí
tenemos que cuando el tiempo es igual a
cero la concentración del ente es la
concentración inicial y cuando ponemos
el tiempo igual a una t pues tenemos la
concentración de a al tiempo te que hay
entonces regresamos y vamos a integrar
desde cero hasta t con respecto al
tiempo en esta integral y por aquí que
estamos integrando con respecto a las
concentraciones de a vamos a integrar
desde la concentración inicial de a
hasta la concentración de a al tiempo t
y ahora pues vamos a resolver esta
integral aquí realmente lo que tenemos
es x a la menos 2 con respecto de x si
tomamos a x como la concentración de a y
la integral de x a la menos 2 con
respecto de x es x a la menos 1 entre
menos 1 cierto entonces esta integral es
la concentración de a a la menos 1 entre
menos uno y por supuesto no se nos puede
olvidar este signo menos y la estamos
evaluando desde la concentración inicial
de a hasta la concentración de al tiempo
t ahora esta expresión de aquí se puede
simplificar muchísimo por ejemplo
podemos cancelar este signo menos con
este menos 1 y la concentración de a
elevada a la menos 1 es uno entre la
concentración de a estamos evaluando
desde la concentración inicial d
hasta la concentración de a tiempo te
aunque todo esto es simplemente esta
integral de aquí y bueno es igual ahora
por aquí tenemos una acá y esta integral
pues es simplemente una t y la estamos
evaluando desde cero hasta t
desde cero hasta t
bueno entonces nada más tenemos que
evaluar esta expresión en estos extremos
y restar los o sea que tenemos uno entre
la concentración de agente concentración
de entre menos 1 entre la concentración
inicial de a que uno entre la
concentración inicial de a y tenemos que
esto es igual a la constante de
velocidad de la reacción
por esta expresión evaluada en estos
extremos o sea de menos 0 pero pues eso
es simplemente t
entonces aquí tenemos la ley de
velocidad integrada para reacciones de
segundo orden ley de velocidad
integrada que bueno algunas personas
también les llaman ecuación de velocidad
integrada y realmente no importa como le
llame siempre y cuando sepas a qué nos
referimos pero bueno esta ecuación es
súper útil cómo vamos a ver a
continuación y la mayoría de las veces
la vemos un poquito reordenada 1 entre
la concentración de al tiempo t es igual
a la constante de velocidad de la
reacción por el tiempo más 1 entre la
concentración inicial de a y otra vez
necesitamos más espacio y aquí si lo
observa puedes ver que tenemos otra vez
una ecuación de una línea recta que hay
porque esto es una constante esta es
otra constante entonces tenemos
constante por la variable más otra
constante
esa es una recta de la forma y igual a m
x
master entonces si por ejemplo gráficas
el tiempo en el eje de las equis y luego
gráficas 1 entre la concentración de al
tiempo t en el eje de láseres pero
observa que tiene que ser 1 entre la
concentración de al tiempo t en el eje
de leyes entonces si se trata de una
reacción de segundo orden lo que tiene
que quedar es una línea recta donde
además la pendiente de esa línea recta
es la constante de velocidad de esa
reacción y además la ordenada al origen
de esa recta es uno entre la
concentración inicial de a que llegamos
un pequeño dibujo por aquí digamos que
tenemos aquí el eje x y el eje y
entonces en esta gráfica en el eje de
las x vamos a poner al tiempo
en el eje de la siesta vamos a poner uno
entre la concentración de a al tiempo
que hay uno entre la concentración de a
al tiempo t
entonces si tenemos una reacción de
segundo orden
la gráfica tiene que ser una línea recta
y la pendiente de esta recta
diente es igual a la constante de
velocidad de la reacción como estábamos
viendo por aquí y la ordenada al origen
este punto de aquí esta altura como
también estábamos viendo por aquí la
ordenada al origen es uno entre la
concentración inicial de a ok esta
altura de aquí es uno entre la
concentración inicial de a ok entonces
esta es la idea detrás de la ley de la
velocidad integrada o ecuación de la
velocidad integrada como prefiera
llamarle pero de reacción es de segundo
orden